we all keep secrets for most of us these
are nothing more than minor embarrassing
details about ourselves but some of us
have dark secrets which if discovered
could destroy lives for years the
residents of circleville ohio received
bizarre threatening letters from someone
who somehow knew every salacious detail
of their personal lives the letters cost
people their jobs their marriages their
freedom and sometimes their lives over a
thousand letters were sent over 20 years
yet somehow whoever wrote them got away
with it
let's find out why
[Music]
circleville ohio is about 25 miles south
of columbus in the late 70s it was the
typical small american rural town with a
population of 13 000 circleville has
been described using cliches like nobody
locks their doors and everybody knows
everybody a problem with small towns is
that it's hard to keep secrets this
story begins in 1976 circleville
residents started receiving anonymous
letters postmarked from columbus
handwritten in strange block letters and
the letters were full of details of
their private lives there was never
return address but the writer was
clearly someone with intimate knowledge
of the town's residence and their
secrets gordon massey was the
superintendent of westfall schools in
circleville when he got to work on the
morning of march 3rd 1977 there was a
letter waiting for him dear sir
according to my gf you have asked her to
go out many times and have asked the
other female bus drivers too this must
stop at once for the good of the school
and families if they are not stopped i
will be forced to write to the school
board and i would hate to do that the
prey on another man's girl is
untouchable i suggest you find yourself
a pimple face and start up with her and
leave my girls alone
and more letters followed each with
escalating threats one even said they
would cut the brake line in his car if
he didn't stop sleeping with his
employees that same day a letter arrived
with a school board describing how
massey approached assaulted and
sometimes carried on extramarital
affairs with the female bus drivers the
writer demanded massey be fired he
wasn't he denied everything and there
was no proof of any wrongdoing but a
couple of weeks later the school's vice
principal received a letter near school
talk to gordon massey about his affairs
i shall warn you i know the truth i want
to protect your school it has a good
reputation you should keep it like that
i shall send you proof about driver
number 62917
she has a child in school there now i
shall prove this shortly i expect him
then to be discharged you'll see that i
am telling the truth
that letter was oddly specific
though he didn't name anyone he used an
employee number only someone with
intimate knowledge of the school and its
employees would have that information
they looked up the number 62917
it belonged to bus driver mary gillespie
[Music]
mary gillespie was not someone you'd
suspect of a scandal she had a nice
group of friends and a close family who
lived nearby and according to everyone
who knew her mary was a good friend an
attentive mother to her two children and
a loving wife to her husband ron mary
led a quiet life but that would all
change in march 1977.
mary opened her mailbox and found a
strange anonymous letter and written in
eerie block letters stay away from
massey don't lie when questioned about
knowing him i know where you live and
have been observing your house and know
you have children this is no joke please
take it serious everyone concerned has
been notified and everything will be
over soon
this is upsetting but rather than tell
her husband ron she kept this to herself
and over the next few weeks more and
more letters came in and each one was
more threatening than the last and each
revealing more personal information the
writer obviously knew where she lived
but also what bus she drove and the
names of her husband and her children
still she ignored the letters so the
writer raised the stakes he wrote
directly to mary's husband ron gillespie
the circle the letter was gaining
confidence the letter to ron described
his wife's affair with massey and
threatened to kill him if he did nothing
about it the writer claimed to know
where ron worked and described his
vehicle a red and white pickup truck ron
and mary were definitely being watched
and when ron confronted mary about the
letter she denied having an affair with
gordon massey but she admitted she'd
been receiving similar letters for a few
weeks they decided once again to ignore
them but two weeks later ron received
another the letter writer had now
changed the handwriting to be even
blockier probably to make it harder to
trace and this letter informed ron that
he knew that he had done nothing about
mary's affair with massey and if she
didn't admit the truth the writer
threatened to put up signs and
billboards and broadcast the truth on cb
cb radio yeah the buses communicated
with each other with cb wow cb takes me
back it does oh yeah i used to drive
truck in the 80s really
this is hecklefish at the chop express
and i'm talking to whoever's listening
out there it's like i told my last wife
i says honey i never drive faster than i
can see besides that it's all in a
reflexes
you're called classic that was a good
one anyway besides the letters mary and
ron started getting phone calls from the
person they believed was writing them
they didn't know what to do or who to
tell about the threatening letters and
calls so they went to the people they
trusted the most their family this
turned out to be a huge mistake
to fight back against the anonymous
letter writer ron and mary gillespie
enlisted the help of ron's sister and
her husband karen and paul freshhauer
they put together a list of suspects
from the beginning mary suspected
another school bus driver named david
longberry david made a few passes at her
and became resentful when she rejected
him so they decided that paul freshhour
would write to david longberry in their
letters they told david that they knew
what he was doing and threatened to go
to the police if he didn't stop
immediately
they stopped and everyone's life went
back to normal oh boy what this is the
part where you say everything was fine
until in august 1977 the letters and
phone calls had stopped but now
signs appeared suddenly ron and mary
began seeing signs posted all over the
town
written in the same crude block letters
they accused gordon massey of having an
affair with mary some even accused
massey of having an affair with mary's
daughter tracy who is only 12 years old
yeah this isn't cute anymore i hate this
guy i get it so did ron and mary in fact
every morning ron would get up early and
drive around town removing all the signs
he could find so his wife and daughter
wouldn't see them on their way to school
but things get worse
mary gillespie went out of town to clear
her head ron stayed home in circleville
with the kids on the evening of friday
august 19th the gillespie's home phone
rang the caller said he was watching the
gillespie house and he knew what ron's
truck looked like this set ron off he
started ranting that he recognized the
voice as the letter writer and was
finally gonna put a stop to this so he
grabbed his pistol kissed his daughter
goodbye hopped in his red and white
pickup and tore out into the night he
find the guy ron gillespie never made it
home oh no
[Music]
around 10 25 pm just a few minutes after
ron gillespie left his house on his way
to confront the letter rider his red and
white 1971 ford pickup crashed into a
tree though just a few miles away from
his house on familiar roads ron
apparently failed to make a turn he was
partially thrown from the truck and
declared dead on arrival at the hospital
when pickaway county sheriff dwight
radcliffe arrived at the scene something
looked strange a bullet had been fired
from ron's gun but there was no bullet
hole anywhere and no actual bullet just
an empty casing the gillespie family was
convinced this was no accident they
believed ron had caught up with the
letter rider took a shot at him and lost
control of his truck while in pursuit or
they thought maybe ron was run off the
road but an autopsy showed ron's blood
alcohol level was 0.16 twice the legal
limit as far as the sheriff was
concerned this was the answer ron had
too much to drink left the house in a
rage and lost control of his vehicle
case closed the gillespie family wasn't
having it ron wasn't much of a drinker
and he wouldn't leave his kids in the
house alone unless he was dealing with
something urgent they wanted the sheriff
to investigate further but he wouldn't
sheriff radcliffe called the whole thing
an accident ron's family demanded to
look at the truck but they couldn't it
was sent to a junkyard and crushed just
days after the incident it was later
learned that there was a suspect in
custody but they passed a polygraph test
it's assumed the suspect was david
longberry but his name was never
released the town now had more questions
than answers why did the sheriff
suddenly change his mind who was the
suspect why was the car quickly disposed
of and why is the sheriff refusing to
investigate the town of circleville now
had a conspiracy on its hands and the
letters kept coming now people were
receiving letters claiming the sheriff
was covering up the truth
nobody was more vocal about this than
paul freshhauer ron's brother-in-law but
sheriff radcliffe wouldn't budge and two
years later we get a twist
two years after the death of her husband
ron mary gillespie finally admitted to
having a relationship with gordon massey
but but but but but she said the affair
started in 1979 after receiving the
letters oh come on
she said the stress and the trauma
brought them together look i ain't
buying whatever she's shoveling hey
that's what she said well she did the
time might as well do the crime eh
that's one way of looking at it mary
hoped that finally being open about her
relationship with gordon massey the
letters would stop they didn't stop did
they they kept coming over the next
seven years mary gillespie received
almost 40 letters she was called a
cheater a homewrecker a murderer some
letters threaten the lives of her
children the signs continued too graphic
images and vulgar language about her
were posted all over town specifically
placed on her bus route so she and her
children would see them in 1983 mary had
enough she was driving her school bus
near the intersection where her husband
ron died a few years earlier there she
saw a sign posted that talked about
massey and an inappropriate relationship
with mary's daughter using very obscene
language she stopped the bus and went to
grab the sign
then she noticed a piece of string
connecting the sign to a box about the
size of a shoebox and inside the box was
a handgun propped up by styrofoam blocks
and the string was connected to the
trigger when the police examined it they
told her the gun was loaded and set to
fire if mary had pulled on the sign by
standing in front of it she would have
been shot in the face or chest point
blank the circle of the letter writer
was no longer just a nuisance he wanted
to trade ink for blood but whose gun was
this don't tell me the serial number was
filed off it was but one of the
forensics technicians was able to
recover it the gun belonged to a man
named wes wesley uh who the hell is wes
wesley wesley worked at enhancer bush in
columbus when police asked them about
the gun he said yes it was his but he
recently sold it to his supervisor at
work it was a supervisor paul fresh hour
what
so the gun belonged to paul fresh hour
the man who kept trying to find answers
to mary's husband's death the man mary
and ron first went to to help with the
letter writer when the police questioned
ron fresh hour about the gun he freely
admitted that it was his but it had been
stolen a few weeks earlier
he just forgot to report it
according to company records paul had
taken the day off the day the trap was
placed but he had an alibi still the
sheriff brought him in for questioning
paul insisted he was being framed and
the letter writer was behind everything
and if the sheriff had done his job and
caught whoever was writing the letters
mary would have never been in danger and
ron would still be alive well the
sheriff showed paul fresh hour a few of
the circleville letters he asked paul to
copy them as best as he could which he
did he then asked paul to write a few
sentences using that same handwriting if
he could so paul did the sheriff looked
at what paul had written and claimed
this was a perfect match and placed paul
fresh hour under arrest for the
attempted murder of mary gillespie
[Music]
what the sheriff told him to copy the
lettuce yup and that's how the
handwriting matched uh-huh no any judge
would throw that evidence right out well
paul fresh hour was found guilty and
sentenced to seven to 25 years in prison
what
that's some sloppy police work but at
least they finally got the guy and while
fresh hour was in prison don't tell me
the letters kept coming oh no
[Music]
while in prison paul freshauer continued
to claim that he was innocent he was
imprisoned in lima ohio over 100 miles
from circleville yet somehow the letters
kept coming and like always they were
anonymous written in that weird blocky
handwriting and postmarked columbus ohio
by now the letters were going all over
central ohio not just circleville the
prosecutor in paul's case was accused of
corruption the coroner who did ron
gillespie's autopsy was accused of child
abuse which actually turned out to be
true so who knows maybe there was a
cover-up over a thousand letters went
out and some were even dusted with
poison
sheriff radcliffe demanded that the
warden get paul fresh hour under control
the warden insisted there was no way
paul could be writing these not even
putting paul in solitary confinement
stopped the letters so in 1990 after
being in jail for seven years paul fresh
hour was up for parole the parole board
said that his ongoing campaign of hate
mail proves he's not ready to enter
society the warden even spoke up for
paul and said he was a model prisoner
and absolutely could not be writing the
letters still his parole was denied and
shortly after that paul received a
letter of his own fresh hour now when
are you going to believe you aren't
getting out of there i told you two
years ago when we set them up they stay
set up don't you listen at all no one
wants you out no one the joke is on you
hell no one of this letter i saw the
paper great news great the sheriff loved
it
do you believe it now do you
wait wait did they say when we set him
up yeah it did interesting isn't it they
finally released paul fresh hour from
prison in 1993 after 10 years he
proclaimed his innocence until his death
in 2012. around the same time paul was
released from prison the circleville
letters stopped and there hasn't been
one since when paul fresh hour was
arrested this case was officially closed
but there are so many unanswered
questions but even after all these years
the case is still fascinating every
major true crime tv show blog and
podcast have covered the circle of the
letters case even the show unsolved
mysteries did two episodes on it in 2021
the cvs program 48 hours had two fbi
experts examine the letters one said
paul definitely wrote them the other
said paul definitely didn't write them
so let's look at the evidence and see if
we can figure out who done it
[Music]
there are a few theories here are the
primary suspects some think the answer
is simple paul fresh hour did it it was
his gun his handwriting that's it now
could paul have sent hundreds of letters
from prison unnoticed all postmarked
columbus ohio over 100 miles away no
sure i guess it's possible nope some
think it was david longberry the bus
driver who made a pass at mary who
rejected him longbury was troubled he
got caught abusing a young girl and left
town in 1993 to avoid prosecution it was
around this time that the letter stopped
but there is a large group of people
including professional investigators
like martin yant who think paul's wife
karen deserves a closer look while all
this was going on paul and karen
freshhour were going through an ugly
divorce really really nasty when martin
yant was investigating the case he said
he'd never seen someone hate another
person as much as karen hated her
ex-husband paul fresh hour yet
discovered a witness that could have
possibly exonerated paul and she made
herself available to the defense but was
never called she was also a bus driver
who had the same route as mary about 20
minutes before mary found the trap this
witness says she saw a tall man with
sandy brown hair near the sign and
parked next to the sign was a yellow el
camino why is this important well first
of all paul was short with dark hair but
at the time karen freshhour was dating
someone and he was described as tall
with sandy brown hair any chance karen's
boyfriend had an el camino no
but karen's brother did oh no the wife
did it paul was framed maybe
karen had multiple motives mary had
cheated on her brother ron who is now
dead and if she could frame paul for the
murder well that solves two big problems
for karen if you read the divorce decree
paul pretty much got everything the
house retirement savings the kids but if
paul goes to jail
karen gets everything in fact paul
insisted this was her plan all along
paul even believed his son mark stole
his gun a few weeks before the incident
paul didn't report it because he didn't
want to see his teenage son go to jail
and paul's son mark became severely
depressed and took his own life in 2002
and some have speculated that he just
couldn't deal with the guilt anymore and
karen testified against paul that she
had found dozens of letters in her home
that she claimed paul wrote when the
court asked her to produce those she
said she threw him away also during the
divorce proceedings karen visited paul's
sister and asked to borrow a typewriter
and paul's sister thought this was an
odd request yet at about the same time
the circleville letters were no longer
handwritten they came typed martin yant
does not paint a very nice picture of
karen freshhour but others come to her
defense saying she was a victim of
domestic abuse and that paul was the
culprit all along okay so who did it
well nobody really knows but i think it
started with gordon massey's son william
and potentially david longberry the
early letters were very specific and
contained details that you'd only know
or even care about if you worked in the
school district karen and paul freshhour
knew mary but they wouldn't know her
employee number and once mary and ron
gillespie shared the letters with the
fresh hours i think the fresh hours
found a way to wage an anonymous war
against each other while going through
their bitter divorce things quickly got
out of control as they tend to do and
lots of people got hurt but i can
understand why all the players in this
story are portrayed the way they are the
story of the circle of the letters has
so many layers of mystery it's only
natural that if we can't solve the
puzzle let's at least try to put some
pieces in place and every good story
needs a hero that's paul freshhour a
husband a father wrongfully accused and
sent to prison the villain is karen a
vindictive wife obsessed with destroying
her husband mary is cast as deceitful
and unfaithful who had an affair that
set the entire story in motion ron is a
victim a man trying to protect his
family who had the courage to confront
his attacker and whether by accident or
not was killed but the more you look
into the story and i encourage you to do
so there is a ton of material about it
you'll see that each of these characters
is not so black and white
everyone is a shade of grey now i have a
hard time believing paul fresh hour was
the only letter writer but also he
wasn't the saint that a lot of the
podcasts claim him to be
and karen isn't as awful as is widely
reported in my opinion the circleville
mystery has no villains it also has no
heroes all this story has is victims and
if you want to solve this mystery
because of curiosity i think that's okay
everyone loves a puzzle but there are
some people who want to solve the
circleville letters because they think
justice wasn't served and they want
someone to pay
i'd encourage those people to really
think about what these families and the
community endured for 20 years before
demanding punishment they should ask
themselves
haven't these people been through enough
thanks so much for hanging out with me
today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor and
like subscribe comment share all that
stuff really helps a small channel until
next time be safe
be kind and know that you are
appreciated
did i hit that is that on there look
it's i'm leaving it
[Music]
you